okay let's go to the phone's 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 why don't we start with our caller
from the three one seven area code
callers listen for your area code you
won't hear a click or a chime or any
kind of noise when we bring you on but
you will be on when I say your area code
let's start with three one seven who's
this either David my name's Christian
Christian what's on your mind today hi I
just wanted to include you or to extend
this conversation I've been having with
my various leftist friends people
identify as anarchist socialist
communist leading all across the
spectrum I wanted to extend this
conversation to you in the age of Trump
how useful is self-identifying as a
progressive I'm sort of where we were
coming from with that if I say I'm a
socialist or dam or if I'm an anarchist
there's a certain epistemological or
ideological heritage that I can draw on
there are different groups for different
people
writers and speakers whom I can sort of
ground myself in to to to to orient
myself in in the world however if I if I
say I'm a progressive we feel that
that's more like an it's a very American
term and it's it's a much more nebulous
much more doable problem the kind of
orient myself around the specific that
specific sort of term or I think I got
so questions I'm gonna answer your I'm
gonna answer your question Christian
you're sort of cutting in and now I hope
we're not on speakerphone maybe it's
just a bad signal you've got here's the
thing what you're basically talking
about is the value of labels I for a
very long time have questioned the sort
of political debate of labels because
labels are unclear I'd much rather talk
to someone about my political views and
their political views and whether we
have shared values and shared policy
ideas or disagreements and sort of go
from there what you're suggesting is
that some some labels have more of a
historical context than others the
problem is the ones you're naming like
I'm an anchor
I'm an anarcho-capitalist most Americans
you're going to be talking to won't know
what the history and people that you're
referring to and specific tenets are of
that so I think that while you may be
right that some of those terms have been
around longer than progressive as
concepts a lot of people have no clue
what the hell they are so I don't think
that it's particularly useful and I'd
focus more on talking about issues if I
were if I were giving you any advice
thank you so much all right appreciate
the call thank you so much